When you're thinking about
a longer presentation,
it's often best to start with the
building blocks of your elevator pitch.
The who, what and why for your app.
And use that as a basic set up for
a story.
You'll have to tailor the story
to your audience, but generally,
you can talk about a group of
people who have a problem, and
then talk about how your
app addresses that problem.
To tailor your story to your audience.
Take time to present to someone like
the people you'll be presenting to and
ask them which parts
resonated with them.
It's very likely they care about
different parts of your app than you do.
You can make a story around
the development of your app as well.
Your prototyping process has given you
a lot of check points along the way, and
a lot of user feedback to work
with in building that story.
Often, the story will look
like we saw the problem and
came up with the solution,
that's your first prototype.
When we tested that solution though,
there were challenges
pointed out to us by users.
Because of their feedback,
we developed our concept further and
have arrived at this
shiny new prototype.
When you share your current
prototype with an audience,
be sure to share it natively.
If you're building an Android or
iOS app, pass some phones around the
table with your prototype pre-installed.
If you're building a web app,
make sure your audience has laptops and
can interact with it themselves.
You'll know you've done this right,
if people in the audience explore your
prototype, find something they like, and
show it to the person
sitting next to them.